lovely welcome to planning planning West
my name's Justin carriage I'm the chair
in front of me are the members counselor
members of the committee and to my left
and right officers of the council who I
shall ask to introduce themselves Thank
You chairman mr. Wasco committee
services Mason - legal services I'm the
planning manager in my role as an
impartial advisor to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal Town
Planning Institute planning committee
members are not bound to by the case
officers recommendation or by any oral
advice David million ship planner Shawn
Gardner assistant planner thank you just
draw a members attention to the fact
that there is an update sheet quite a
brief one today so if we go to the
agenda apologies of absence and pain the
councillor fielding substituting for
councillors Giles Thank You councillor
just any disclosures of interest thank
you very much
email received on application 1801 four
five eight yes I've had one of those I
think most of us would have had that
good eye
I'm the ward member for the sperner Park
application number seven on the agenda
so I'll I'll actually although I haven't
objected or supported I will step down
so we'll need to choose a chair at that
point to chair that specific
pick item counselor thank you that's
ward member for the Ludington one you're
stepping down for that are you stepping
down okay
okay in the minutes can I confirm and
sign the minutes of the meetings held on
the 25th of July and the 15th of August
and minor thing on the front page it
says apologies and it seems to have
omitted my name I did provide my
apologies and notice okay which ones
that first page the 25th of July 18 okay
that's noted now counselor okay so okay
happy with it good so get straight to
the planning applications then item
number 4 which is page 13 on the agenda
and it's Hardwick house and over to
Victoria Chataway I think yeah I've just
taken them both together councillor
update sheet the result of which is
recommended for a deferral right okay so
that's been deferred because of a red
line issue recommended by officers for a
deferral on I'd propose that if I can
find a seconder for that second to
cancel all those in favor with deferral
you know thank you very much
okay item number five
Milhouse Stratford Road wooden whirring
which is page 27 on the agenda and this
is we have David here but he'll be
leaving the authority shortly thank you
very much for being here and thank you
for being here tonight but Victoria
Chataway is going to take this one as
well
Thank You chair hmm planning permission
is sought for the demolition of existing
stable blocks in the erection of two
dwellings across the site the site is
denoted by the black dot and and the
site is located within the village of
Appleton woman the site is outlined in
red on this slide Canosa
wording there we go okay so the red line
there the pink line denotes the
conservation area and the dark red
outlines are listed buildings this is an
aerial photo of the site with the red
line approximately shown overlaid on top
the entirety of the site falls within
the Greenbelt
and the special landscape area of Arden
these are existing photos of the site
their site
this being the existing stables on the
site open paddock here this is the view
from the road of the site over here and
this is open paddock to the north area
of the site these are further existing
photos of the site again from the road
the stables in the site the application
site falls within the village boundary
of Wharton woman as defined by the
neighborhood development plan it falls
at the very edge of the boundary as
shown here with open countryside
immediately to the south of the site
this is the proposed housing layout of
the site for two dwellings the first of
plot one being approximately where those
ding stable and plot to being where it's
currently open particle and this is
innovations of the proposed dwellings
the dwellings of a traditional design
using local brick and of a height of
approximately eight point seven five
meters at the highest Ridge point and
there shows the proposed floor plans and
this is a perspective view as seen from
the open countryside looking into the
define village boundary and then finally
this is the existing access to the site
obviously it's a crescent shape site the
access is over here the photo is
purposely taken from the driver's seat
so you can see in both directions what
the visibility is leading into the site
thank you thank you so now we will hear
from Kemper mark McCall from wooden
Warren parish council who is supporting
the application you have three minutes
and I'll tell you half a minute before
the end good evening thank you for
letting me come up and say my piece I
think the the parish council would just
like to support the application we feel
that the design of the building is a
good design for the village in keeping
with other properties in the area it's
in the village boundary of the
neighborhood plan which is the crucial
thing for us really although as the
planning officer said it's on the edge
of the boundary there it is within the
village boundary and that land within
that area as far as the parish councils
concerned has been allocated for
development potentially so we think it's
a tis a good place for development
within the village
and yeah just like to say that we
support the application really great
thank you
any questions suppose it's only a few
hundred meters from the village centre
where they've got the village shop and
post office and it's another it's
another two no 300 metres onto the
railway station under school so yeah
it's close close to the village centre
it's closer to the village centre than
the affordable homes and things that
we've recently put in so and our next
speaker is mr. Peter Fenton
who is the agent Thank You chairman the
planning officer states in his report
under the heading green belt for the
development to be considered as in
filling it should be accepted as
development on a site between existing
built-up areas this limitation is not
found within the framework 2018 or its
predecessor it is not found within core
strategy policy cs10 or the supporting
text with the greatest of respect this
is an unjustified limitation which is
the creation of the planning officer
what the core strategy says under policy
CS 16 housing development is this the
council is committed to giving local
people the opportunity to influence
where homes are built in their
communities and encourage parish
councils to prepare neighborhood plans
that identify sites to meet or exceed
housing requirements wooden woried
parish council has responded accordingly
with a neighbourhood plan that has
complied with the basic conditions to
have regard to national policy and be in
general accordance with the core
strategy the neighbourhood plan has been
made as a statutory development plan by
this authority the approach taken in
this neighbourhood plan is to define a
built-up area
three where new housing development is
supported in principle within the
Greenbelt and this proposal is within
that boundary the approach represents
the planning judgment of the local
community through its neighborhood plan
on infill development and is consistent
with national planning policy and the
core strategy
hence the previous speaker from the
parish council supports the proposal and
you'll see in your committee report the
extract from the consultation which says
this development is limited in filling
in the village as supported by the
neighbourhood plan for the purposes of
the scale of development the
neighbourhood plan is the most relevant
part of the development plan the power
given to neighborhood plans to shape
direct and help deliver sustainable
development would in my opinion be
frustrated if planning permission for
development that is consistent with the
policies of the neighborhood plan is
denied the planning judgement as
expressed through the neighbourhood plan
is that limited infill development is
achieved by allowing in principle new
housing development within the built-up
area boundary as you will see in the
committee report there are no other
specific objections to this proposal so
far from being in appropriate
development in the Greenbelt this
proposal is consistent with the
development plan and planning permission
should be granted accordingly and I so
request this committee to do that thank
you thank you any questions thank you
very much
can I take it from what you've just said
that you do think this is constitutes
limited infill and I'm mind standing
from what you just said it on the basis
that it is it says so in the in the NDP
as within the built-up area boundary and
a second question once you've answered
that if we as a committee are minded not
to accept that it's limited infill what
are the special circumstances he opened
for this the would outweigh any harm
that's identified right okay my view is
very clear that no as I said no
definition of limited infill in national
policy note
finishing in the core strategy so what
the neighborhood plan has done as part
of the statutory development plan is to
interpret Greenbelt policy for limited
infilling by drawing a built-up area
boundary and as the policy says housing
development within that boundary will be
supported in principle so supported in
principle in accordance with Greenbelt
policy and that is the view of the
parish council but it's their plan and
they're very clear this is limited
infill development in terms of if you're
not with me on that and you take the
view that it's inappropriate development
you have to give great weight to
Greenbelt policy and you then have to
look whether there are benefits from the
proposal that outweigh that harm to
Greenbelt policy now I haven't presented
the application on that basis at all but
in terms of you would give great weight
to the the harm that there would be harm
as a matter of policy but no harm other
than that in my view and the planning
officer goes through that it's not open
countryside it's not going to encroach
it doesn't impact on historic buildings
or it doesn't cause sort of enlargement
at large at the urban area so the
purposes of the Greenbelt policy it
doesn't harm it other than as a matter
of policy housing coming forward
supported by the parish council within
the infill development high quality
development bringing new people into the
village they have to be weighed up with
that degree of complex but I must
emphasize that isn't my position my
position is one of liens any other
questions kind of arms this is an
application for two versions correct one
is your replacement for what
no they're two stable buildings so these
are two additional dwellings so the
village there are no trees coming down
well other than trees which are aliens
thank you thank you
right okay so as far as I know there is
no specific number noted in the
neighborhood development plan for a
number of dwellings within written word
nor is this site specifically allocated
for housing development in the
neighborhood plan I didn't get I think
it was the numbers of how many how many
numbers should be taking I can answer
that if you want yeah it's written on
page 32 of the report okay thought so
we'll move on 12:17 was 84 so that isn't
relation to were to move in itself
that's part of the fact that this is a
category 2 local service village so you
would expect a proportion of that to go
into wooden were in itself but that's
not over all of yep
so Casa bombs well I was going to ask
you and this is probably not
we had a Greenbelt house which was
bigger than a tennis court the other
week we had a summit business in the end
if at any point I want to decide visit
at what point do I ask because there
seems to be some confusion like if you
want to have technical questions and
then if you want to do it in discussion
yeah
cash the Vaudrey it's the point of
clarification III it appears under
Greenbelt policy this wouldn't be
permitted unless there's a special
circumstances but the argument from the
planning office or Planning agent was
that under the neighborhood plan this
this if you like would be permitted can
you sort of perhaps reiterate the
argument on the neighborhood plan and
where you stand
precisely on the wording in the
neighborhood plan that may or may not
permit this okay so the the neighborhood
plan follows a very similar wording to
the core strategy in how we assess
Greenbelt development so a boundary line
was put around the application site so
it defines that as the village boundary
in terms of Greenbelt policy you still
have to consider infill development and
whether something is considered to be
appropriate infill development the
definition of in infill development
there isn't one so officers have to deal
with that on a on a case-by-case basis
and how we've consistently considered
other sites we have looked at other
sites as an authority as a whole and
considered that where perhaps there's a
something between you know between two
houses or between two built forms that's
infill when something is directly
adjacent to open countryside as is is
the case in in this instance we would
question whether that is infill so
that's how the officer has reached the
recommendation that this isn't
considered to be infill development
although it is within the boundary of
the neighbor
as defined in the neighborhood plan and
just surviving just flopping at one
point so because you don't defiant as
infill you therefore don't think it sort
of comes within what's the meaning of
the neighborhood plan language and
therefore that's why you refused it is
that just so I'm clear elevations of the
two properties then you showed us
another image which shows looks like
timber boarding on the I think though
yeah this is just one property so this
is a plot to remove only showing the
elevations of the one property on the
slide so there would be a slight
difference to material timber cladding
proposed on plot one and not on yes I
think I'm going to take you back to
follow up from councillor Ward ruse if I
may I think I'm clear on the infield
side of things well I'm not clear on is
what is what exactly is in the
neighborhood development plan it sounds
to me from the agent that if this has
been identified as an area that can be
built on and by virtually the fact that
it's within a built-up area boundary is
that right and if it is is that not in
itself special circumstances that would
outweigh any harm okay so the policy h1
of the neighborhood plan says the
built-up area boundary of water Moen is
defined by the village boundary back to
you that a new housing within the
village boundary will be supported in
principle over there supporting text any
new development will therefore be
restricted to limited infill within the
village boundary in accordance with
paragraph 89 of the National Planning
framework that's obviously now being
updated but by a very similar paragraph
and this will have the effect to focus
if any new
relevant towards the most sustainable
locations within the neighborhood area
so it still talks about limited infill
and it's still for us to make an
assessment as to whether we consider
this is limited infill in Greenville
terms thank you can I just clarify you
said stable location and if so can you
sustainable stable sorry I'm I didn't
hear your word for the location so the
app the application site is currently
occupied by stables yeah yep yes
okay so Oh tends to bounce I'm just
checking the applicant said it was in a
sustainable location 300 meters from
anywhere in the trainer that you would
agree with that yeah yes I think we
would consider it to be sustainable okay
let's move to just debate anyone have
anything thank you thank you well as far
as I can see it's inside the built-up
boundaries of the village it's a local
service village and it's in accordance
with the NDP it's a sustainable location
so I see no reason why they shouldn't go
ahead I've just come in there I I agree
with nearly everything you said however
I don't believe it's in it's in
accordance with our our Greenbelt policy
or even the local services wouldn't the
wouldn't policy which quotes national
policy about limited infill
so it's all down to the question of
business limited input do we consider
this to be limited in full either so
councillor Richards thank you I think
I've been quite agree with you
council carriage the
[Music]
what I was trying to imagine my head was
that the infill side of things Neff
indeed it is infill I don't think just
because it's within a built-up area
boundary that actually when we look at
it on the map it's very separated from
the main conurbation of [ __ ] I don't
think that constitutes limited infill
therefore we have to fall to special
circumstances now I was based on the
what I heard from our speakers I was
starting to err on the side that
actually you know the fact that this is
in a neighborhood development plan
suggests that it is special
circumstances but as having had
clarification now it's not as black and
white as I first thought tonight as well
let's believe by our by our speakers
very clearly within the NDP does rely on
the paragraphs about Greenbelt and cs10
of our own core strategy and I don't
think this satisfies those paragraphs so
I will be going with the officers
recommendation and I propose we do
refuse on that basis well as far as I'm
concerned the design is okay it's in the
village
it's a sustainable location if you could
have a job in Birmingham and get there
in about 20 seconds if you run course on
your bike to the special and that's why
some time ago we had a great big house
in the Greenbelt and we went and looked
at it and had a summit visit and we did
feel unanimously that the officer in
that Kent
it was very futile and we approved it
and I'm of the same opinion that's why I
suggested that as far as I'm concerned I
would like to approve the application
and and quite happy to propose that
against I know you know do you feel that
your comments to the last speaker we're
not actually correct in the Greenbelt
but Paris I'm concerned I would prefer
to site visits
but I would be happy to propose you can
solving yes if I can quote from page 32
of the report limited in filling or
partial complete redevelopment of it
previously developed brownfield site
which is this is subject to it not
having a materially greater impact on
the openness of the Greenbelt so it is a
matter of opinion as to whether what is
proposed will have a greater impact from
the Greenbelt than what is already there
thank you okay well we haven't got a
second to get IIIi completely yes so it
can't afford it that's leaving me out
actually this is one where because I
haven't seen the site I think it's it's
in Greenbelt but the neighborhood plan
ambiguity I actually care towards my
position is either I side with the
officer or if there is unanimous support
for what Peters proposed actually in
this instance probably wife one sees it
one could be unambiguous about whether
it is in fear or not infill I think it's
quite difficult to sort of without
seeing it would he know that so I'll I
would I would default to probably
seconding councillor Richards motion
unless there was a view that people are
keen to actually go and see in which
case if it if it's obvious then I'm open
to a different view just go quick come
back on your I think you're quite right
though it is a matter of opinion and
again it rests on if if this has a
greater impact a materially greater
impact on on the openness of the green
boat you know you can you could say that
because you're not going to see it very
much from the road but because it's kind
of said against existing houses when
when it's viewed from the fields that
you're going to add extra landscaping
which is going to improve things because
of the high quality of design all these
things leads with not having a greater
impact if that was the way you were
thinking but to to cut things short
we've had a proposal to
follow the recommendation and refuse I'm
going to second that that I would say
though there were at least two people
here who want a site visit but we have
to go through the first things first if
you don't if if you want a site visit
you might want to vote us down and then
vote for a site resume I don't I'm happy
to go with the proposal so the proposal
before us is to refuse planning
application all those in favor of
refusing to chairman all those against
refusing three abstentions
so have we got another proposal well as
far as I'm concerned I'm quite happy
with what's in front of us if you want
to propose and I'm quite happy to
propose that we approve it in okay
that's one thing what would you we've
got a proposal and a seconder we're
going to have a few comments in between
and so I'm quite happy with it
I don't know why my colleagues are
prepared to go against numbers
recommendation and we need to understand
that I think so I think I think we can
you give us a reason councillor on
either I think it's got to be you know
you think it is limited in filling do
you think there's very special
circumstances if it's not limited in
filling or you think in a sustainable
well I think we have to address these
things of redevelopment of a of a
previously developed site potentially
not having a materially greater impact
on the Greenbelt these are the reasons
and we need to say why we're going
against officers
it's in a brownfield site it's in the
middle of a village it's in the in the
area for building it has got buildings
on there it is if you like in their
sustainable location the opposite said
she liked the design of both of the
houses they were in keeping with the
Greenbelt so as far as I'm concerned
only the Greenbelt is that our problem
is our interpretation of where they are
in the Greenbelt and as far as I can see
if you could see there in between all
the other houses there in the location
there in the village okay so you're
saying it is infill who proposed this
okay - the bars proposed it on the fact
that it is in film okay
are you happy to second it under those
circumstances right
so all those no conditions so if you are
minded to approve I would recommend the
following conditions standard three-year
condition and condition limiting it to
the approved plans condition requiring
no demolition to occur during the
nesting season a finished floor levels
condition details of services and
utilities locations and then external
materials a planting scheme hard
surfacing details full drainage scheme
details provision for electric vehicle
charging the wheelie bin condition and
the water buck condition and the removal
of permitted development household a
permitted development
is there a conditional they drive that
would be the hot Sun - thank you can we
have a conditional so I think a scheme
of this size we wouldn't normally put a
construction management condition on we
could add one I would argue it might be
onerous just because of the scale of the
development and the fact that they are
normally limited just by the mechanisms
of what you'd have to adhere to
however by oh by all means it is it is a
condition we can add okay
excuse me check that there was a second
string to counsellor organs suggestion
that was that construction traffic
shouldn't be allowed to park on the
driveway and councilor organ I'm sorry
we can't do that yep all parking is on
site because that's a rather dangerous
road so if people signed upon on the
road particularly near the station end
of it we've got to make sure that
doesn't happen right okay so we have all
that sorted are you happy with all those
additional issues yes the management and
the organ lovely so all those are in
favor of granting permission for this
application so now three German okay
again just two German abstain one lovely
well this committee has resolved to
grant planning application 1800 175 no
house
right so we're going to go on to
application 1801 four five eight now
gallows blocks in Knights Lane Alison
young isn't here so are you ready
Victoria in a few moments I'll let you
finish off the last one will take us
through that Thank You chair and there
are updates to this planning application
but the remote recommendation remains as
per the report which I will get to at
the end of the presentation so the
position of the site is denoted by the
black dots on this slide the site is
located in Teddington within the defined
built-up area of Stratford and the
application site is edged in red on this
slide the site currently contains
garrotting which is no longer in use the
site is accessed from knights lane there
is pedestrian route through the site
which run from knights lane to Lawson
Avenue proposal is for an additional
dwelling which is here which would be
attached to the side of the development
that was previously approved for for
dwellings approved under application
reference 1703 137 ful so the register
the red hatched area shows the
previously approved scheme this
application seeks to amend the
previously approved parking layout for
that scheme the previous approval is
shown at the top the now proposed
parking layer is shown at the bottom so
we have the changing location of the
turning head additional parking space
here and an alteration to how the
parking layout works over in this corner
this shows the floor plans and proposed
elevations of the site
you'll note that the elevation includes
a larger first floor than ground floor
that's to enable access through this
portal here which is where the
pedestrian access is through the site so
it goes through their rights that one
yes or it goes through the site here
this is proposed street scene
innovations so these houses here have
already got consent and the proposal is
simply for this dwelling here in terms
of elevations
this is photos of the site and the
existing pedestrian route through the
site
so from knights lane it through the
garage site and then from Lawson Avenue
it's a pedestrian access that lend leads
itself into the garage carriage right
here this is a photo of the existing
garages and again the access into the
site the recommendation is for approval
thank you thank you very much
and we are going to hear from objectors
a resident mr. Alan Nash welcome and
your have great so you do have a
presentation
just tell the officers when you want
them moved on I guess yep
lovely so you're like three minutes and
I'll give you half a minute warning at
the end okay this is a back land site
surrounded on all sides and immediately
adjacent to other houses bungalows and
Gardens the site contains trees hedges
and a green area which supports wildlife
our property at 79th lane shares its
border the entire length and the 7455
meters to the northwest we're not
against the development of the site and
we were generally accepted the previous
approval for four houses
despite the application information
suggests the extra unit will necessitate
removal of a large green area of land
with established trees and hedgerows
approximately four metres by 35 metres
which provides a wildlife corridor
linking gardens adjacent to the site a
point which was echoed in a community
meant by the CBRE the application goes
against course strategy policy is
concerned with natural environment and
design and distinctiveness cs6 proposals
will be expected to minimize impacts on
biodiversity and where possible secure a
net gain in biodiversity while
safeguarding and where possible in
enhancing existing habitats we are
concerned that the county ecologist has
provided is no object in comments on the
incorrect basis that the trees will not
be removed but they will the
applications failed to include a tree
survey or bat wildlife survey but as
this site along with adjoining trees and
hedges supports bats the council should
not be considering the planning
application without one cs9 seeks to
ensure high quality design including
making best use of the on-site assets
including landscape features avoiding
developments with little or no public
dive diversity biodiversity value and
appropriate design having regard to
height width and depth of building the
extra house now proposed is just trying
to squeeze too much onto this site and
would result in an excessive balkan
appearance
creating a monolithic brick block that
splits and spoilers the development the
application the applicants incorrectly
suggests the proposed terrace of
replicants replicates an existing
Terrace on Knights Lane which we
certainly do not agree with the
council's own figures and recent
articles in the press state that the SDC
has and is forecast to exceed its
housing requirement it quotes and this
strengthens our hand in resisting
speculative development on sites which
are not most suitable or preferred we
believe this is such a case the site is
not reasonably suitable or capable of
accommodating the extra house is
contrary so our strategy policies cs6
and CSS we asked for refusal of this
application thank you any questions the
trees are as you see in that photograph
where this an area that was there
measures the about four meters by 35
meters that just shows one area vote and
that's a links this sort of back the
rear gardens which feel close and
Knights Lane and that links the gardens
with those gardens on Lawson Avenue but
it Street surveyor so a tree said that a
survey has not been done for this site
or wildlife survey okay counselor Barnes
are you saying that the green in the
previous application all this green is
stopping but this application it's got
to go yeah that's the case yeah it is
addressed on on the previous application
there was an area which has been
landscapes and trees plantation trees
which would have minimized the impacts
of this total removal and this and also
the house borders defense okay any other
questions
No thank you very much and we are going
to now hear from the agent Steve Bromley
welcome and you as you know have three
minutes and I'll give you the 30 minute
30 second warning
Thank You German the application is
before you at the request of the ward
member who has concerns about the
proposed parking and turnin arrangement
I think I'm right in saying that the
ward member accepts the principles of
the development that it complies with
the housing policies of the core
strategy and the draft neighborhood
development plan the higher authority
has also initially expressed concerns
about the parking layout and turning
area the applicant discusses concerns
with the higher authority who
recommended modifications to the parking
arrangements and this was for plot 1 & 2
and they recommend how I thought he
recommended minor changes to the parking
layout and the turning area accepting
this advice an amended site plan plan
has been submitted the planning you've
seen today the parking spaces have been
repositioned the parking spaces for
plots to have been moved from a long
side plot 1 and will now be in front of
plot 2 which is clearly a more practical
and convenient parking arrangement the
turning space has been redesigned making
it larger the applicant has also
submitted a vehicle tracking plan that
demonstrates delivery vans will be able
to turn within the height within the
site the higher authority have accepted
this plan I understand the case office
carried out further round of
consultations and notifications with the
amended site plan and high authority
have now confirmed in writing that they
have no objection the case officer gives
full support to the application as
amended and finally comment has been
made about limited space for parking
however the 12 spaces proposed for five
dwellings is a standard of provision
that exceeds the parking requirement
that would have been required under the
council's previous residential parking
standards they also exceed the minimum
parking standard in the council draft
development requirements supplementary
planning document chairman the
application will provide a well-designed
modest 2-bedroom dwelling that fits in
well with the approved scheme we have
resolved the parking layout and turning
space to the satisfaction of the case
officer and the higher authority that
members are now able to support the
application thank you very much
any questions councillor Vaudrey the
neighbor mentioned trees sakuya's
comment on confirming that the new
application versus the old one there is
that also for the photo that row of
trees going and then secondly and if you
know the number of trees going and why
why you think that's acceptable and
secondly there was a question about no
bat survey I am surprised the other
surveys I don't want compulsory my
surprise who is know about survey can
you explain why yes I've never carried
out a tree survey it looks like a very
scrubby edge of development site there
are no trees of any stature on this
piece of land all I saw when I was on
the site are elderberry trees so I think
these are trees of no importance on the
issue I would say incidentally that as a
result of the development there'll be a
significant increase in green space on
the site because these dwellings will
have quite long Gardens
they'll be green spaces people of Planet
bushes and trees so I consider there
will be a net ecological benefit in the
long run in developing this site mostly
the site at the moment is mostly hard
standing and garages so there's an
increase in open space and greenery
answer the question about the bats I
mean I actually spoke to the county
ecologist a long time ago about the
potential for bats on this site they've
looked this but both applications that
they don't consider there's any
likelihood of bats on the side okay
thank you councillor fielding
Oh top of the two plans it shows I
presume trees that are going to be
planted along the edge of the
development on on the right hand side
there you're going to do away with the
trees when you build the new extension
or terraced house but is there going to
be garden the other side of the house
that's going to go right the way down or
you're going to fence along side of the
road
take a step back with it I don't really
think there are trees as you imagine
trees on that strip along land down the
side of the site as I say I think
there's some elderberry bushes that have
grown quite tall I don't remember seeing
any large stature trees that you
consider to be significant I mean I
think that that site plan illustrates
quite clearly this it the architect
hasn't actually colored green the open
space which is all the back gardens so
as I've said previously there will be a
significant net increase in green space
on this sides I think we can see the
garden there to the right
no normally No thank you very much and
we'll go now I think to the ward member
councillor wealth has five minutes five
minutes if you wanted you don't have to
use five minutes
if I might start are saying that this
development has permission for four
properties with enough space around the
development to keep the biodiversity and
space to parking and which all the
neighbors and myself were happy with but
now an extra squash team property has
come along to compromise this and as you
can see from the amount of objectors has
upset everyone due to its over
development this new unit squashes right
up to the boundary where the vegetation
along there will have to be removed in
order to build this vegetation has an
enormous amount of biodiversity within
it and there are bats believe me the
neighbors have seen them along this wall
of vegetation and no bat survey has been
done this vegetation also creates a
natural barrier to the bungalows on
whitfill close and two of these
bungalows
if this goes ahead will now look out
onto a two-story brick wall instead of
hedging and trees this boundary would
not have had to be removed in the
original application of four properties
the forum says that no trees will be
removed but I suggest that there is no
way this fifth unit can be built without
removing it as it's buttered up so close
to the boundary we have a five-year
housing supply there's no imperative to
this extra squeezed in unit to be
approved the extra unit now creates bulk
and mass and congestion and is out of
character with the surrounding area
nowhere in tinning turn or Knights Lane
has a unit being created with an under
Croft stroke archway the turning space
in the original approved plan there was
plenty of space for vehicles to turn not
now now it's left to what appears to be
a parking space which of course people
will park in and then there'll be no
room to turn larger vehicles will have a
huge problem visitor parking the
developers tried to address the concerns
of highways and myself about visitor
parking so stuck one at the site which
looks LOD and out of character and if
you look at the plan behind it is a
column which you'll have to back into
it's interesting that this is because I
objected to turned in parking on site
and they're still tandem parking you
need to be aware that all parking for
this development will be on site as
there is no parking on the streets
around as they have yellow lines all
around people will park in the turning
back
which looks like a parking space this
site is going to look so congested and
squashed finally the resident who lives
at number 15 Lawson Avenue has a legal
right to drive his vehicles through the
site and into his back garden this is
not a private arrangement but a legal
one and he drives a van of seven and a
half tons which will now have to drive
under the arch this arch restricts the
size of his van if ever he wants to buy
a new one
hi we seem to have taken no notice of
the fact that there will be a regular
vehicle movements under this arch which
will compromise with pedestrians and
over the owners of the new properties
this is not as stated by the planner
just for pedestrian access it's the
vehicle access - I'm sorry I didn't ask
for cyclists I was away at the time and
it completely escaped my mind however I
do believe that before you make any
judgment on this development you should
be satisfied that there's a bat survey
done which there isn't and it should be
satisfied that all screening will stay
which at the moment indicates that it
won't and you will be satisfied that
there would not look out of character
the four units will find the fifth has
destroyed the entire character and
appearance CPRA have also objected we
must take note of the fact that they
also object to the strip of greenery
being taken down they feel just as
strongly as we all do and they usually
only comment when it's important to them
I suggest to you that you have many
reasons to refuse this application
overdevelopment no bat survey promptness
of site and parking an issue out of
character loss of trees and biodiversity
loss of privacy - the bungalows on width
or closed and the five year handle and
supply I would urge you to refuse this
application thank you thank you very
much any questions
councillor Richards thank you I've been
trying to work out in my mind how that
whole one-way system would work and I
assumed that there would be a I wasn't a
hundred essential on the pedestrianised
station of that that will route through
can cars drive through there now and
they can't
the owner of number 15 Orson Avenue
parks his vehicles in his back garden
and he has the right to drive his
vehicles and the vehicles of the three
flats that he owns into his backup do
you jump the gun a little bit that's
helpful
yeah so on this picture here that blue
line is the what's the footpath now yeah
you're kind of okay you sort of seem to
insinuate that if this development
permitted then it would you would be
able to drive through that way you yes
you tell me you can't yes you can but
you but he's restricted to the height
and size of his bag yeah I think you're
purchasing too much on the one
individual okay can cars get up that
blue where that blue they get up there
and through to the other side no thank
you good okay did you have a question
careful fielding any other questions
Albin the property I think well can we
do we can do this some technical
questions yeah okay thanks any other
questions
okay Thank You counselor well thank you
technical questions anyone got any tapes
I thought so my two points so what why
is this before us without a bat survey I
may be one why always thought the bat
survey would have been standard and
secondly can you summarize what is gay
on that strip of green and is it elder
boy tree is whatever we're told all kind
of what is in there and should it have
been analyzed for biodiversity or not I
think the simple answer I can give to
that is that we consulted the county
ologist they have come back giving no
but representations they have
subsequently been consulted again I
believe in the update sheet they're once
again said that they don't wish to make
any representations and normally they
would be the ones that are recommending
that surveys tree surveys
anything along those lines based on
their expertise so we've relied upon
their expertise in May getting to where
we've got to so that's the batch survey
just we don't recommend that service
county does was another question
fielding
Drive Thru basically go right the way
down yeah it is a little confusing and
it took me a while to to understand this
so this is a pedestrian access those
bollards at this end and there's just a
green either side and there's a
pedestrian access through the middle
here you can obviously drive a car from
Knights Lane into the existing garage
site it being a garage site and you
could drive your car all the way down
here and then you can access the rear of
these properties and you can go no
further than the various properties so
this property here has the right to
access that I did didn't I yeah so you
so there is there is an right of access
for the resident to come through here
through the site here to access the rear
properties so the pedestrian access is
through here there is vehicle access
through the site that is legal to to the
rear of these properties at this point
well would you like very briefly to say
anything are you happy with that
come come come to the mic please it's
not real of properties it's one property
that has a long enough back garden that
vehicles parking and that's the access
that has a legal right to have including
a van okay thank you
that's thanks good that was
clarification that's what I wanted can
you turn there turn to turn the thing
off cancer off doesn't matter okay macer
going to clarify something for us all so
I don't be the bearer of bad news but
basically rights of access or easements
to give them their formal name or
actually property rights and not
planning rights therefore if there's an
issue regarding a right-of-way with the
person who believes he has a right and
the owner of this site dinner is a
matter between the two parties it's not
for this appalling committee to consider
thank you very much for clarifying I'm
not sure where everywhere I'm gonna go
councillor Barnes all I was going to ask
is are the exit and entrance and that's
exactly the same as they were when it
was garages yes what we're taking down
all we're taking down old garages and
the entrance into what is the current if
garage site will be the interest into
what will be the housing site cancer
fielding was saying but is that blue
route through is that currently it's not
currently highways is it because there's
a bollard at the end so it's blocked off
so therefore have we got to give it
change of use
yeah I think I think I can answer that
question counselor that blue route is
currently a public right
currently a pedestrian link it is a
footpath yes you notice I nearly said
public right away I don't know that it
is so please don't assume that it is a
footpath link so theoretically you could
what I'm sure in Printz practice you can
walk from Lausanne Avenue through to
through its nicely okay the way through
now I have a question on it was raised
that there are no I think undercroft
that this whole through up building that
there's none really in the area and it's
kind of add character you've got any
comments on them
yes chairman whether or not there are
any in the area the character of this
Terrace of houses he's not enormous Lee
dissimilar to the character of other
terraces of houses in the area in
officers opinion okay thank you very
much
okay so Richards well we're on character
Kiki I think you flip down one slide so
on the right hand side which is that I
believe it's better proposed we've got
white buildings and then on the left
above it's all red am i am i
misunderstanding this are we changing
the the bottom image so all of these
already have approval so there's already
approval for two vended properties and
two brick just extending the rest okay
no more questions to debate anybody
councillor fielding in my opinion the
fact that there is no right well there
is pedestrian right-of-way down that
road we don't think we can grant or
unless I'm wrong and legally a vehicle a
right-of-way which will have to be
granted for people to go down there I
also don't like the idea of having an
archway there which knowing what young
people can get up to it could be a
source of problems in the future but I
don't suspect that's a planning matter
but it is something I would okay one
comment from solicitor as to confirm
what Dowell said there probably is a
right of way on foot and she imagined by
prescription rules that has been
acquired over 20 years anyway there may
be a vehicular access right as well but
like I said those are property matters
they're not planning matters okay thank
you
Thank You chair
I should go very quickly address to the
archway point I don't know what you did
when you were younger in archways but
things definitely have changed I
actually drive through an archway to get
to my property and there's no issues at
all
said having looked at particularly the
top-down view and try to understand the
site and where it is where it's located
I do feel that as an over development of
the site it feels to me like we're
packing in an additional half just to
squeeze one in for the sake of squeezing
an extra one in it does seem as
character and out of keeping with the
locality and on that basis I would be
inclined to propose a refusal of the
application but I'd like to hear what
everyone else says ok I'm going to say
something I'm at the moment tending
towards your point of view
I heard what comes to the RAF said about
the undercroft and what our officers
have said about that maybe not that
specifically but I think that's this
area if you go and look at the houses
they're very open around here
they're very spaced out houses all
around that the surrounds and this is I
think much more dense and it's only a
small development but it's right in the
middle of a lot of other houses which
are all nicely spaced out so I think
this is just that one house too much for
the character of the area so so I do
agree with you I'll second that actually
but we'll hear from other people as well
I hadn't I should propose but I'm quite
happy to just add to the reasons for
refusal and that we are we we as a
committee identified it and we both to
push this through that we identify a
harm by virtue of the over development
and the benefit of a single dwelling
does not outweigh that home can't appeal
ding ok councillor Barnes yes I'm
concerned on this but I mean I
appreciate that the count accounts are
happy with the layout after a number of
goes and there's sort of a pea
working on the County Council in that
respect well because they use a minimum
standard and all kinds are getting a lot
bigger these days lovely
any others we're going to need a policy
reason I think the description we've
given definitely fits into a policy if
not several policies we're talking about
over development we're talking about
well we've said it all the reason I
think there was a very lucid description
of why we choose to turn this down or at
least propose it is it cs9 can you tell
me would those reasons fit into cs9 I
think great we have a ten as well
so we've got a link cs9 it may fit into
several things design of character I
think we've had a very lucid set of
reasons given good I'm sure we can sort
out the actual policies with these
reasons we'll fit into so we have a
proposal on a second
we're confirming that we do need a
policy number yeah we're just making
sure
otherwise I'm gonna backtrack and that
would be embarrassing chair I apologize
for the hiatus I think you've hit the
nail on the head with CS 9 and the
issues that I heard raised were over
development out of character and out of
keeping with the area I have a policy
reason to hang this on we are proposing
to refuse this application all those in
favor of refusing ok this committee has
resolved to refuse planning application
1801 4 5 8 full night's lame to do we
can have 5 minutes we got a 5 minute
break ok
great so the next application is 1801
for seven - what page is that page 55 I
am going to be stepping down for this so
I'll be looking for a nomination for
chair for this item absolute nominations
given we have someone at the table who
was a vice chair and has chaired this
planning committee very well before I
don't see why we shouldn't propose
councillor Audrey Audrey as you can see
it's come as a complete surprise - ha
okay it's great
other other any other nominations in ask
you any other nominations
no no no that's good okay so all in
favor of that that's a great thank you
very much
so we are going to look at application
1801 for 72 stroke ful Bernal Park
Burford lane constructional car park and
access modifications so if I could
invite the case officer to present the
details please Thank You chairman
planning consent is sought for the
construction of a car park and a
modified access to the site to provide a
convenient parking area for visitors to
spurn or park of Mossberg cops the
location of the site is indicated by the
black dot the site is more clearly
defined here by the red line boundary
and access to the site is shown from
Burford Lane this is an aerial photo of
the site with the approximate boundary
of the site shown in red the site is
located in the open countryside within
the Greenbelt and the special landscape
area of Arden and the Vale of Evesham
control zone these are existing site
photos top being the existing access to
the site on the bottom the existing
field this is the proposed site layout
which is for the proposal to layout a
car park of 30 parking bays and for mini
bus bays this is the access to the site
and how that would be improved so the
very bottom of the access would be
improved by implementing tarmac the
access to the site itself would be
restricted by a height restrictive
barrier in this location and a proposed
parking meter this is an indication of
what the area would it appear like and
the parking meter the barrier itself
would have not only the height
restriction but a gate that would go
across it when the car park is not in
use this is the access to the site
photos taken from the driver's seat to
show visibility in
both directions and the photo at the
bottom I can probably show you more
clearly from a video that I have is a
neighboring field access can you just
bear with me a moment for the video so
this is standing in the road looking
towards the site looking towards the
access that's the existing access to the
site back gate to the left is the
neighboring gate access and then looking
back towards the road the recommendation
is for approval chair thank you
thank you very much so I just looked to
the list of who's down to speaker I've
got no one trying to speak for this
application guys confirm there's no one
here plan to speak for it nope in that
case on my list councillor Paul Harvey
from spur Knoll parish if you'd like to
come up you have three minutes mr.
Harvey it counts my Harvey when you
start we'll start the clock Thank You
chairman this is a very rare appearance
by council we normally contend to that
officers have less say but to put that
into context although this is an
isolated location there are nine
residences within a few hundred meters
and the majority of those have objected
to the application for a variety of
reasons I'm going to speak purely on one
of them which is the most consistent the
objection and concern unfortunately our
area recently has become prone to crime
and one of the residences in particular
burgled three times in quick succession
by a particularly unpick you lean Asti
gang of people who'd obviously spent
some time surveilling the property
from adjacent farmland or footpath so
fear of crime is a very significant
concern in in our area the police in
fact originally objected to this
application on that basis the crime
reduction and Community Safety Officer
on the basis they were concerned and
they still are concerned even though
they withdrawn their application they
say they're still concerned about
offenders leaving cars in the car park
without suspicion while they carry out
their crime so in a nutshell those are
the concerns of the parish and the
residents of despair and if you were my
need to approve we're particularly
concerned about opening hours and the
gate being locked at night and that the
applicants should follow the high
quality of construction that's proposed
with grass tree and grass reinforced
paving which has not always been used in
their other car parks thank you
Thank You counsel Harvey any questions
for members no thank you very much so
next on my list here is mr. Steven Lake
wishes to object to the application so
mr. Lake if you'd like to come forward
have a seat it's the same time length
again three minutes mr. Lake whenever
you start we'll start the clock rolling
hello my name's Steve Lake I'm the
person that's immediately Minds the
farmgate that access is the same
driveway that this application is all
about I exit onto that same driveway and
it's that that brings the main concern
that my entrance and exit is hidden from
the highway view when approaching from
supernal Lane
it's the video itself doesn't show the
drive from spurn lane to my property and
you certainly can't see the gate in the
drive from spur lane you are within a
matter of meters before that's visible
with 30 potentially 30 cars I'm sure
they're providing car parking spaces for
people
may arrive and it's fair to say they
weren't all arrive in one go but the
increase in traffic on that gate is
going to cause the congestion if only
because my entrance and exit is hidden
my gate opens outwards into that space
and it will impede the entrance itself
in the applicants submission they almost
by suggestion
said that they own the entrance they
don't that entrance belongs to the local
highways it's not under their registered
titled neither it is under mine
display lines look fine on that video
and I agree they don't look unreasonable
however during the growing season the
hedges do not get maintained as well as
perhaps they might I'm sure that's
financial restrictions on the highway
side and the the bank's left and right
of the road are raised in excess of a
meter high add to that 600 millimetres
grass cover when you are sat in the
driving position trying to exit that
side you don't get the clear view that
is suggested there so my objections are
mainly on the grounds of highway safety
the route is used extensively by
cyclists and it's only a matter of 10
days ago that we had a cycle is knocked
off broke the hip and very close to that
location so it's it's a there are no
footpaths the the public thought about
the public right-of-way that that
currently exists actually exits just 100
metres up the road onto Burford line so
any current users of that site actually
walk down Burford lane so there is a
substantial amount of of organised walks
that are using that site at the moment
the proposal isn't equal to to enjoy the
walks in it any more than they could
currently already do is to bring other
people in other cars into the location
and most of those people are our dog
walkers we've got a dog no dogs no
problems and I have to say I've got no
problems with the heart of England
generally I think I did an excellent job
this particular location
in a single track line is one of highway
safety in a mile of spurn Lane they have
other sites I've gotta Fred I got to
stop you there your three minutes is up
but I think I think we gave the idea so
it's now questions from I invite
counselors to ask you questions so
counselor fielding first of all where do
people evidently use the footpath you're
saying when they come in with groups
where do they park their vehicles at the
present moment okay well I'd say the
pleasure of that is that they're
generally speaking walk further said
they parking their cars much further
away in truth we don't see any so they
are organized groups potentially parking
in the local pub which is the mother
half camp which is about a mile down the
road but we don't see them parked there
is of course the new car park recently
granted permission a tayden way which is
a mild is further down the road from
spur line that's also part of our
turbines and forests no problems that at
all because the splay lines are
perfectly good and there's easy access I
would also say that just refused to come
just further down the road at the heart
of England currently have planning
consent for a cemetery mr. daga I'll
stop you there if I may I think we sort
of answered that key point counselling
if you're happy with that whom we've on
councillor bombs is next it's not a farm
it's a it's Gardens and it's second
entrance and if anyone goes direction we
head any more questions from councillors
meiosis 1 just to clarify the point you
said that most people who use it now are
walking so does anyone do you ever see
do regula see cars parked on the road
then my for road safety might be it
might be safe safer and road safety if
they were off off the road in a car park
such as this ok answer to question but
the only cars we ever see parked outside
our gates of and evening of course in
couples and we often have to be to get
access
young people a council feels like you
never know what's going on okay mr. Lai
thank you very much for your
presentation
okay so now I'd like to invite the ward
member so councillor coach you have five
minutes I was kind of no comment in
general as with the the other speaker
I'm in favor of increasing access to the
countryside this is increasing access to
the countryside the heart of England
forests great organisation we're really
really happy that they're on our
doorstep on many of our doorsteps
so in principle it's great idea there
may be issues with this specific side I
don't know I'm just here really to
answer questions if you wanted me to any
questions the councillor carriage no
thank you very much so now we turn the
matter to technical questions for the
officer so any technical questions for
members councillor Barnes the County
Council haven't raised any objections to
councillor Richards could you bring up
the slide with that shows the grass
[ __ ] layout and how it all looks so
just so I'm clear the gray that goes all
the way up that's going to be the hard
standing so that the stone and gravel
and that sort stuff from the right-hand
side as the grass great is that correct
a stone this is one part of its grass
screech I can't quite see from yeah
that's grass street and then that's
grass reinforced plastic okay so that's
obviously with generally permitted
within Greenbelt and accepted I think
this is a farm field one can lay a
certain level of hard standing in its
general use is that right how much is
that per missus just taken advice and my
colleagues here and there is um an
amount that you can lay under permit its
development we're not quite clear how
much that is but it has to be for
agricultural purposes so this wouldn't
fall within that okay no thank you
councillor organ council fielding my
mistake with regards to the gate opening
and closing I presume there is a warden
that supervises it and the second
question is have the police had any
input into the gate and the design of
the Gateway so yes there is a warden I
believe there are a number of sites in
the area so the warden visits those
sites and would open and shut the gate
in accordance with the hours the hours
there's a recommendation for that hours
of use by a condition on the application
the police were consulted on the plan in
application that initially raised some
concerns over the isolated location but
they removed those objections when the
gate and access and height restriction
and the times were then put in as part
of the proposal so they are happy with
with what is now proposed in terms of
the gate and the height restriction
Thank You councillor Fielding I actually
have three points if I may um has it
been any analysis of the demand whether
there is demand for what seems to be a
fairly large carpark secondly I'm just
curious what lies beyond this it seems
to be stretching
so Ben definitely is there beyond the
plan a property that in due course you
know this takes it narrow a property for
some reason I was just curious about and
thirdly because it is in Greenbelt is
does the special circumstance issue with
Greenbelt apply here and have they
demonstrated that there is a special
circumstance I'll get to you the first
two points sorry can you repeat your
first point to me I'm very sorry okay
okay sorry so the applicant has informed
us that based on other sites of theirs
and other car parks that this is a
demand that they need that's the amount
of analysis it's come from them to meet
the need for that for the local copies
yeah and their business needs and I
believe I believe that there are foot
passive in the general area in terms of
what lies beyond which eventually lead
to so that there's no built no built
properties to the north but there are
public rights-of-way in in the general
facility that that serves and in
relation to the Greenbelt can we just
bear with me a moment
thank you for your patience yeah in
relation to greenbelt we look at this in
the same ways we would have a building
so it's whether this has a general
impact on openness which the officer in
their assessment of the report deemed
that it wouldn't that's helpful thank
you so any further technical questions
if not I'd like to open it up for debate
oh yes plan shows the road can you tell
me another car park a mile down the road
does that plan action doesn't go that
far does it
either way it's outside of the demise of
this photo it's off to the left of the
photo is that where the pub is that they
were referring to
okay let's let's start the debate if I'm
a councillor Richards Thank You chair um
I'm really struggling to find any
grounds for us not to accept this the
only thing that concerns me is that the
size of the thing it is quite large and
we don't really have anything that
suggests that there is a desperate need
for that amount of cars but I can see no
policy grounds that I can pin my hat on
to refuse this so I would be proposing
that we grant info and allowing the
officers recommendation is that either a
seconder or any other points other
councillors of rush to raise councillor
Barnes as you know mr. chairman I'm not
far from that another part of England or
walking trees and whatever and sometimes
it's absolutely for the car park where
30 40 goes and sometimes there's nobody
there at all really depends on the
weather
so there is a great demand or does
appear to be a demand for the five key
or the ten key more and so there is a
need and there is much place ran there
to park I couldn't understand why the
locals aren't happy with it been like
the first picture I can't really see a
reason very usual second okay so we have
a second for councillor Richards motion
just can i clarify one point I had a
couple of issues about conditions do we
discuss that now before we go to a vote
so can I just raise two things I'm can
serve on pointed out I think we're both
familiar with where these meters are
near where we actually reside and I
would once I would like to request some
condition that said that they were
somehow not seen from the highway they
was discreetly hidden because you drive
past them he just looked so out of
keeping so I would ask for condition on
that and also the parish council asked
about operating hours and when those
goats gates were open and closed I
wondered whether there was some
discussion that we had about what was
deemed reasonable for opening hours the
opening hours they proposed a summer in
a winter season so it's 6:30 a.m. until
9:30 p.m. in the summer and 6:30 to or
5:30 p.m. in the winter and they give
the months of what what summer in winter
okay so so that that's the maximum
extent of when they would look to
operate it's likely that they would shut
before before those times but that
that's the absolute maximum based on
that their overall management but
certainly that's what the condition
requires I'm with regards to insurance
I'm sort of screening to the parking
meter I think it's very reasonable to
the other condition on that basis any
other conditions I'm not happy I'm happy
in the summer very could be open that
late because
people will if they haven't got back by
8 o'clock
they're either lost although they're
gonna spend the night there so I think
it should be more of 8 o'clock
than later than that any other
councillor bonds I wondered whether we
could put a condition all about litter
bins because quite often the place is
well by your road it's atrocious
but people leave so I think if it is
going to be not a public but it is
public but most of the people are
members so they don't play I think we do
need some litter bins and some care
actually I would concur with that
so litter bins again discreetly hidden
from the highway so you can atleast see
them from the highway but they should be
what and also called me a dog litter bin
as well specifically only only openly I
remember so many comments on on the
opening hours we missed whoops are gonna
be attached to my proposal so I just
wanted to say I'm entirely comfortable
with the screening of the stand
I think they've litter bins are a very
valid point and I'm surprised actually
that we and I overlooked it the opening
hours is very clear on page 62 of our
report the applicants have requested
7:00 a.m. as a start time both in summer
and winter and 5:00 p.m. in the winter
9:30 in the summer we've given them that
additional half-hour leeway to allow
them to be able to get to unlock and
what having given bit of leeway on on
policing that I see actually no reason
why we should tighten them up or change
them the reality is in the summer
particularly the sun's out until 9:30 10
o'clock some people don't even start
walking into late o'clock so I think it
will be over restrictive to put anything
else on top I think these are absolutely
fine
ok I would if I may can sort of fielding
I'd concur with I just seeing how people
use it in there where I live I do accept
sometimes you get home from work and you
want to go so I think it's ok in the
summer so on that basis and there's any
other comments we are and we're so
you're you're happy with the conditions
councillor Richards we were proposing to
grant permission for application
18 / 0 147 to such ful with the addition
of the conditions we've just discussed
Council which is proposing it was
seconded by Councillor Barnes as I
recall are you happy with the conditions
Caliban yes okay yes agreed so put it to
the vote
all those in favor to grant then the
plan application is passed and the
council resolves to go on planning
commission as per we've just set out
thank you very much
right okay our final I think item
tonight application what it's two
applications eighteen zero one six one
two four and I listed building consent
eighteen zero one six one three lbc on
one nine eight Ludington Road Ludington
and if we can hear from the officer
Shawn Gardiner on that
okay Thank You chair so in front of us
we have the application site which is
centrally located in the village of
Ludington there's an aerial photo of the
site one nine eight is a mid terraced
property great two listed located
centrally in the village here we have
the block plan planning permission is
sought to remove an existing lean-to
extension and replace it with with a
single-story extension which would
attach to the exist to an existing 1960s
extension it would have a flat roof and
bi-fold doors and the side elevations
which gives you an impression of the of
the site obviously of the proposal so
turning to the photos we have the rear
of number of one nine eight looking
towards number 199 showing the existing
lean-to which will be removed here we
can see the terrace of the three
properties and here we have a close-up
of the rear elevation and the area which
is to be extended and the lean-to which
would be removed and replaced by the
proposed extension okay that's the end
of the presentation German there are no
updates to report and the recommendation
is to refuse the application for the
reason stated on page 71 of the agenda
paper thank you thank you very much and
we should know here from counselor John
Warren de
chairman of the parish council lovely
and you have three minutes and I'll give
you a 30-second warning
good evening mr. chairman councillors
right so I'm Tara Flemington parish
council and here to defend the
application for this small extension and
to reiterate the parish councils support
of this proposal it had overwhelming
support at the parish council meeting
ward member councillor Barnes visited
the site and is happy to support this
also the committee report in the
application doesn't really include our
statement of support in its entirety as
we stated that the use of reclaimed
brick and timber and red tiles is to be
an important factor in supporting this
application which is in line with the
Ludington village design statement which
was adopted by SDC in June 2018 we can
be sticklers with this so we are
supporting this application on those
grounds other factors are and please
bear in mind that this is a real
single-story extension and has never
impact on any street scene parking
issues or ecological matters which
therefore Accords this with cs6 of the
core strategy construction traffic will
access by the rear and the neighbors are
happy with this the neighbours are
happily are happy generally with a
proposal historic England has made no
comment
ecology Department have made no comment
the conservation officer
however wanted a reduction in size which
has been facilitated by the architect to
a level which is now the minimum
acceptable to the applicant to make the
improvements worthwhile both adjoining
properties have had similar and larger
extensions in the past
and although cs8 of the core strategy is
quoted as a reason for objection we
would disagree due to the need of
modernization and upgrading of wiring
and pipe work included within this
proposal and that there is no
substantial harm or loss intended or
would be caused
proposal these proposals are not for
profit but an increase in amenity safety
and a reasonable increase in living
space within this well looked-after
small cottage we believe that these
benefits would outweigh any harm alluded
to within the committee report in the
last paragraphs you may note of the
design visual impact statement you will
see that the officer finds no visual
harm arising from design and scale which
accords with adopted policies cs9 and
cs20 of the core strategy in the last
paragraph of the neighboring immediate
II amenity statement the officer notes
that no neighbors would be affected and
so the development also Accords again
with policy cs20 of the core strategy
Burlington parish council hope that you
will appreciate our involvement by
attending this committee meeting and
take on board our views when you weigh
up the evidence in support of this
proposal
15 seconds lovely thank you any
questions
Kassar organ and thank you chairman
which i think is number 199 now board
fence where the extension is supposed to
go when the lean-to goes so in fact it
will have an impact on that property
because the extension will be higher
than the six-foot fence do you have any
comments on that
okay
Oh can you use your new button pleasure
oh yeah and I think we're going on from
the earth the direct question was was
simply in your opinion I think okay I
was going to go on okay that if you look
at the block plan which came up at the
beginning note that one there yeah so
any you know building materials will
come in from the back and the neighbors
have said that they're happy to
accommodate all that so we have no
reason to suspect that the neighbors
have got any problems at all okay lovely
any other questions thank you very much
and now we're going on to Rob Evans the
agent I think and and mr. James Wright
is it will you both be speaking okay
okay so mr. Wright is it yes okay lovely
so you'll have three minutes I hope to
give you a 30-second warning at the end
okay thank you
so my name is James Wright I'm the owner
of 108 Ludington just takes a few
minutes to support our application for
our small single story extension so the
existing nineteen sixties extension
we're proposing to take down and replace
it's not in keeping with the cottage and
in a bad state of disrepair
we'd like to replace this with something
that complements the rest of our
beautiful cottage were great lovers of
period houses and history and we like to
invest further in this property
enhancing the overall back view of the
house both inside and outside we believe
in investing in older properties and
making sure they are fit for everyone to
live in and happy in the future for very
young and old the original scheme that
was designed in line with the adopted
village statement was not acceptable to
the conservation officer the scheme was
redesigned on the planning officers
recommendation for a more contemporary
approach with more glass and more timber
so that it does not compete the
contemporary approach creates a contrast
of the existing
suggested the conservation officer is
agreed to the demolition of the existing
1960s lean-to this is a later addition
single scan building completely
unsuitable for modern standards of
living the existing flat roof extension
built in the 1980s is no architectural
merit it's poorly constructed and not
energy-efficient and this will be
upgraded the new extension is only 2.8
meters by three metres wide and attaches
onto the footprint of the existing
extension to provide the space for a
modern kitchen diner and bathroom
we've purposely not opted for a
two-story extension to preserve the view
of the existing cottage back wall the
neighboring properties to each side both
have large extensions a one and two
story high the proposed layout was put
forward to to the site constraints an
existing well and main sewer pipe being
one of the reasons why the walls and the
size of extension are where they are
we have full support of the Parish
Council we have full support from the
ward member both neighbors are happy and
have in fact been shown the plant and
are pleased that the rear of the
property can be improved and have a
positive impact on their property as
well as ours we have local supports and
the extension is not visible from any
public points of view thank you for
listening to me and I hope that you can
support our proposal thank you very much
other any questions councillor fielding
it is basically where the hatched area
is there that it's right in the middle
of that it so actually be with inside
the new extension in the floor as a
feature okay that's right yes any more
no more questions I take it thank you
very much okay
technical questions there oh I'm
terribly sorry castor bonds please
forgive me he's just because you haven't
got your dog you've got a bark when he's
not with you
you have up to five minutes counselor no
I shan't take that this is an old
property which really if you like you
can put the picture on it and that'll do
you can see where the well is actually
this is no property that doesn't want
modernized him but he wants to me to
live in there isn't there washing
facilities that I don't always need but
young people do and it's an improvement
to which as the Parish Council of agreed
the neighbors has a look at the
application before it went in they've
all agreed with the first application
the conservation architect wasn't over
keen on the size so obviously we've got
this application they've used the
material she wanted they've done
everything they want and I was rather
surprised that she's absolutely refused
there's a lot of support for it it needs
doing if you go in the building if we'd
know wouldn't say I didn't fit to living
but really isn't any reason for approval
if you listen to the parish council
again they said all the words I want to
so I don't see there's any point in me
going on in the respect that everybody's
happy with it it's modest it's needed
and there will be a glass thing over the
well and it's a lot less inside them
than one next door thank you very much
any questions nope thank you very much
counselor technical questions I would
just mind to us so I know in reason for
refusal not of high quality sensitive
designed and integrated given the
conservation officer is in favor I am I
suppose but I can't sell bonds I'm
slightly surprised so could you just
amplify why this is not of high quality
and you don't think it's sensitively
designed just for my benefit I think if
I may first of all correct counsel the
forgeries question for him the
conservation officer is not in favor
councilor Vaudrey
it's the conservation officer who's
driving this report the the planning
issue you have you heard when the the
parish council spoke they went through
the planning issues and at the end of
each planning paragraph we come to a
conclusion that it's acceptable in
planning terms it's the conservation
issues that are the problem and they set
out for you in the impact on heritage
assets section which starts partway down
page 68 and finishes halfway down page
69 and the issue the concern is that
this building has a rear elevation which
is partially obscured by a flat roof
modern extension and it's partially
obscured by a pitched roof modern
extension which replaced an earlier
extension that pitched roof modern
extension is appropriate to the
character and style of a building of
this age and conservation officer has no
problem with that the flat roof
extension the conservation officer
considers is unattractive as I think the
applicant does and is harmful to the
character of the building by hiding it
but it's there it exists so the
conservation officer is suggested that
some manner of compromise is available
whereby a smaller extension could be
acceptable in conservation terms in that
it would make the property
more habitable but smaller than he's
currently proposed that's not acceptable
to the applicant the applicant wishes to
go ahead with this current proposal
which completely covers that rear
elevation of the building obscurity
makes it not apparent to - from the
outside of the building and therefore
the conclusion is that that is harmful
to its character sorry sorry for the
long answer but if you look at the third
paragraph down on page six b9 that sort
of sums it up okay so I preciate the
clarification my mistake when I am one
kid I read it say well thank you for
that
thank you okay um my question now is if
this is considered to be not acceptable
but the extensions on either side are
probably larger than this as I see it so
where is the home is well we're looking
at the application to this property it's
accepted that there are modern
extensions to the neighboring properties
that is accepted and in fact the
conservation officer in their comments
has suggested that they don't have any
objection in principle to some form of
extension in some ways though because
this is a terraced property with quite
narrow plot you're quite constrained
with what you can do before you actually
disguise the entire rear and therefore
the sort of historic reading of the of
the dwelling so it's I don't know if and
such a question really but yeah I mean
there obviously there are modern
extensions there and they're accepted
prophecy what we're looking at here is
is this application and in terms of the
harm it is to do with the the impact on
the heritage asset it is a listed
building those extensions don't you know
the fact that they've been approved they
don't necessarily mean that this one
should oh I suppose I'm sympathetic with
counsel for disposition and that the
front page of the report does clearly
say conservation team questions yeah no
objection yeah okay on the very front
page it does say conservation team
flowing amended plans no objection yeah
it goes on to say you were telling me
that it goes on to say that there is an
objection is the notation swung clear
the no objection is the principle to
development but there is an objection
the development with my counselor
Vaudrey there there is a compromise
position available to which the
conservation team would have no
objection that compromise position
hasn't been reached and the conservation
team object to the application so for
future reference for our benefit
could we have objection on the front
rather than the objection written on the
front and then objection written on the
main pack okay I think we can end
technical questions there can we yeah so
debate I did have are either 199 or 197
listed in any form and have they had
extensions themselves it appears to me
that 197 has and abut one nine eight
seven certainly has I think that's
obvious from the photos that's been
extended 199 I couldn't find I that's
fine if I may my understanding is that
the properties were listed after 197 had
been extended okay I'm not quite sure if
that's particularly relevant as we're
looking at this application and that's
been covered in yeah and are both one
nine seven one nine nine listed as well
yes okay no more questions okay good
would you like to start us off council
organ yeah thank you
I'm passionate about historic buildings
and making sure that they are preserved
in the best way that they can be and I
think if you looked at this from the
street scene what you see is a row of
terraced cottages
from the front elevation that is what it
is the back however is a completely
different kettle of fish
there have been different extensions at
different times and it's a question of
what is proposed is it going to be more
harmful than what is there already and I
can't see that that is that is the
situation so I would propose that to
actually grant this application and
you've just given the reason that you
don't see there's any so we have a
proposal councillor Richards thank you
thank you have any image of five years
I'm going to agree and second cancer
organs proposal on the basis that and in
a similar way that I think it's a great
shame to lose what is a really quite
attractive rear elevation of the house
the bits on the right that 60s extension
is pretty grotty and when looking at 197
you've got a redbrick extension at the
top and then a 60s extension underneath
am i disturbing something a 60s
extension underneath it almost feels
like that's the forgotten bit further on
element of that entire elevation and I
think it'd be a great shame for just to
let this opportunity go I don't see that
it causes significant harm if anything
actually I think it enhances the setting
of that back elevation of all 197 1 & 8
+ 1 9 9 great that was and that was a
second thing wasn't it yeah so can you
give us some some guidance
at the end if if we get it that way okay
yes counselor fielding my colleagues I
think quite honestly
it needs to be house needs to be
enlarged to make it into habitable unit
and what's there at the moment needs to
be improved and by doing what is in
patrol what is mi basically it's a good
scheme okay no others so we need if we
go for this what conditions are we
talking about we have some suggestions
submission of material samples in
accordance or plans larger details it's
quite standard on happy with that you're
happy with that so chair if I may but to
be agreed with you tomorrow
okay to be agreed yeah lovely council
feeling is just that I feel that the car
parking should be around the back not
voted through the front of the building
yeah won't be okay so all those we have
a proposed on a seconder to grant
application for the reasons given with
conditions to be agreed with the chair
later all those in favor
lovely thank you so we have resolved
grant
okay we've that was for the full
application 1801 six one two four I'm
presuming we can have a proposer and
seconder for the listed building consent
with the same reasons and conditions all
those in favor
good thank you and any oh sorry I'll
have to say that as well council has
resolved grant planning permission for
1801 six one three lbc as well now is
there any other business origin business
no so thank you very much